My husband doesn't cook.
I told him I was craving a steak dinner tonight,
but I was just too tired to make that.
So he told me to sit down
and that he would take over tonight
and make me dinner for once.
So I decided to just trust the process.
But I was very skeptical when I saw how he
cut those sweet potatoes.
Started off by cutting some normal potatoes
and Japanese sweet potatoes
and also some red onion.
He seasoned all of that with some olive oil
and some spices,
gave that a really good mix,
and then put it all on a baking sheet.
I think he realized that it was too much for one,
so he divided it into two,
spread that out evenly,
and then drizzled it with even more olive oil.
Once that was all mixed up,
he popped that in the oven for about 30 minutes,
10 hour, while he got started on his side salad.
He loves making arugula salads,
so he did arugula salads with a lemon
olive oil dressing,
which is actually super simple to make
in one of our favorite dressings in the house.
It's just lemon olive oil,
some lemon pepper,
garlic, and some salt.
And slim decided to join
and help dad with making dinner.
We just prep the salad and set that to the side
while he seared off some steaks.
One thing lucky is good at is making good steak.
He always gets it Right.
So I was not worried about this part whatsoever.
He reverse seasons it,
so he puts on all the seasoning after it's done cooking.
It was perfect.
Just the way I like it.
And then he dressed the salad,
added the Parmesan cheese,
mixed it up with very questionable utensils,
and plated my dinner.